cells at work season one told us how the
body works
cells at work season two code black
tells us what we do to our bodies and
how we hurt them
episode one smoking bacteria and the
beginning
of the end i hope it's not the beginning
of the end
foreign
this is so funny because not only is
this very accurate in that an immature
red blood cell is an erythroblast
and now that they become red blood cells
they are fully matured they are
also presenting this like a true med
school situation where some people in
the classroom were sleepy and yawning me
some people are taking notes and being
very aggressive what do we know about
red blottels
main job is to carry oxygen throughout
the body and deliver it to its vital
tissues
brain the lungs the heart kidneys these
are vital organs that keep
us going in fact if blood vessels the
little tunnels that
red blood cells travel through are ever
blocked that's when you have a problem
if one of those
arteries or blood vessels starts to get
blocked in the heart you have a heart
attack one of them gets blocked in the
brain you have a stroke it's all about
maintaining good plumbing and allowing
these red blood cells to do their job so
i hope they're paying attention
yeah it's okay
[Music]
foreign
red blood cells unfortunately all they
do is circulate throughout the body no
matter what time of day it is
day night when a person's sleeping
you're still circulating blood you got
to feed the brain you got to recover the
muscles
all that good stuff now that being said
red blood cells are only around
approximately 120 days and throughout
that time they're constantly getting
refreshed and new ones are being made
basically when the aortic valve opens
the heart beats
and all the red blood cells start
shooting out to the body
whether they go to the top of the body
in the brain or to the bottom
of the body to the kidneys and legs etc
the goal is
to get as much oxygen quickly to uh
that part of the body and then to bring
back the red blood cells that are now
deoxygenated need to be refreshed by the
lungs
back through the venous system now i
know a lot of times in textbooks we draw
the arterial system as red and the
venous system is blue if you cut
someone's veins i promise the blood is
still going to be red it's just simply
about the tint of the blood when it's
below your skin but in reality it
is still red i promise
[Music]
oh does this person have an ulcer and
ulcer is an opening inside the stomach
from
the gastric acid or perhaps an infection
and as a result bleeding can occur
not i would make a small correction
there it's not the first stage of
digestion
because the first stage of digestion is
a funny word
known as mastication mastication is when
you chew
that is the chemical breakdown of food
that is where digestion begins in fact
you have salivary amylase
which is an enzyme that starts breaking
down sugars
inside the food that you're eating
immediately in your mouth in your mouth
that's right so digestion is happening
here first that's the first step of
digestion not in the stomach
oh wow angry stomachs
can you imagine if every time you
didn't take care of your body you under
slept you overworked
over ate under ate ate something
unhealthy
over drank smoked a cigarette did
something wrong in general
that your body cells actually went on
strike and got mad at you
like imagine your stomach was like my
man
stop freaking out
[Music]
oh
oh
foreign
this is a very accurate description of
how carbon monoxide poisoning actually
happens
because it has a higher affinity meaning
it's more likely to bind with this red
blood cell it actually blocks the
ability to carry oxygen so what happens
if you have a slow leak of carbon
monoxide into a small area like a garage
or a home
you actually start getting sleepy you
get a little nauseous a headache starts
developing
and what's really dangerous is if you do
end up falling asleep you could die
also knowing that the treatment for
carbon monoxide poisoning if you get to
the hospital
is getting a full blast of o2 in your
face why
because if you overload the amount of
oxygen you're getting
hopefully that will create enough
competition that your red blood cells
will actually get some of this oxygen as
opposed to the carbon monoxide does that
make sense
[Music]
so this is why whenever a patient is
diagnosed with bacterial pneumonia one
of the first things we do is institute
antibacterial treatment with antibiotics
the invention of antibiotics has really
gone a long way
in extending life and preventing
unnecessary death however
now we're kind of in the state where
we're overusing antibiotics and are not
not only killing healthy bacteria in our
bodies
by mistake that we need to live but also
you can create resistance
where if you don't take antibiotics for
a long enough period of time
or let's say you take them and you
eradicate 99 of the bacteria you leave
the one percent that are genetically
resistant to it and as a result when
they reproduce each time you take the
antibiotics your body
bacteria actually start building up a
resistance to those antibiotics why does
that become problematic well guess what
a patient comes in with a pneumonia
let's say a sepsis where the bacteria is
now in the blood and then you realize
for all the antibiotic options that you
have which we don't have millions of you
actually
have no choices on what to give that
patient because all the bacteria is
resistant and you've created a super bug
this thing looks like a super bug but i
hope antibiotics will still work in this
case
whoa that white blood cell got some
moves
[Music]
reminds me of michonne from walking dead
who's a walking dead fan here
it's funny that they're going to the
carotid artery there was some plaque
there
visible this does happen and in fact uh
one of the causes or potential causes of
strokes is when you have
such a bad occlusion of the carotid
arteries you actually
impede blood flow to that area so
imagine if you have a lot of plaque
it's blocked off you can get blood to
the brain boom stroke happens now you do
have two
carotid arteries which makes it a little
bit better so you want to keep your
carotid arteries as patent as open as
possible and how do you do that living a
healthy lifestyle
going for preventive screenings making
sure your cholesterol is under control
and know that just because your
cholesterol is high
or the ldl cholesterol the bad
cholesterol is high it doesn't mean that
you might necessarily be doing something
wrong because there are cases
where genetics play a huge role so much
so that your cholesterol is so high that
you could never even get it that high
with a bad diet as a result of your
genetics this is known as familial
hypercholesterolemia there are specific
medications that have recently been
released
called pcsk9 inhibitors again we don't
like jumping to medications but if you
have such a dangerous ldl that it's
causing you a risk
to have a premature heart attack at a
young age maybe it's worth being on that
medication
[Music]
is bad for you i don't feel like i need
to
say that but at the same time i'm gonna
because i want you to know that smoking
increases risk of not only cancers
not just lung cancer all cancers like so
many cancers throughout your body
other lung diseases like copd chronic
bronchitis emphysema
increases in heart disease strokes just
by smoking
we lose approximately half a million
lives
due to smoking in the united states
every year
we in the medical community know that
cigarettes contain over
600 ingredients and when you light them
on fire and burn them that creates over
7 000 chemicals that you're inhaling
into your body and while nicotine may
make you feel good temporarily it goes
away
and it's highly highly addictive it's
one of the most addictive things out
there that's why it's so dangerous
i hope this episode helps you quit
smoking if you do if you're not going to
do it for yourself
do it for these little red blood cells
they don't deserve the stress that we're
putting on them quit smoking
if you need help talk to your doctor
because we actually have so many options
of helping you quit not only from a
behavioral therapy perspective we have
some medications that can help group
counseling etc
talk to your doctor if you have that
motivation share it with us and we'll be
happy to help you out this is a great
medical show
these are bad medical games like really
bad embarrassingly bad
one star games click that to check me
playing them check me playing them check
me out playing them
and as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]